を言い室もありますね一君の最近のオススメスマホゲーム何最近はですね30日連続で
ポケモンを捕まえなきゃいけないというタスクが来たんで
半強制的にポケモンゴーこんにちははじめ施設です皆の衆 wikipedia は
知ってるが wikipedia 人は生きているうちに知らない言葉に合うんですよ
人との会話テレで sns 学校の授業
いろんなところでいる
女分からない言葉が来る道ですけどそれきた時どうします警察しますよねスマート
フォンがパソコンで検索すると思うんですけど検索したら最初の方に出てくるやつ仮想
wikipedia 知らない言葉の意味と管理することを飛び p たりすると
すべててくるんですよそんなニキビでナンデスでもあなたの言葉の数誰がいっぺディア
作ったでしょうか
防空です
するそうですこれすごいんですよしってる人もいると思うんですけど行き縁あって誰も
が編集できるフリーオンライン百科事典つまりこの動画を見ているあなたあなたの
wikipedia を編集できるんですよちょっと引用しますけど世界中の
ボランティアの共同作業によって執筆されるフリーの多言語インターネット百科事典で
あります凄いよだからボランティアで成り立って
いる世界中の人のボランティアで成り立ってる百科事典なんですよ wikipedia
てだから駅メディアに書いてある事って100%正しいことではないんです
ひょっとしたら嘘だ事を書いてあるかもしれない間違ったことが書いてあるかもしれ
ないんだ皆さんもネットの情報を鵜呑みにしないでくださいねばだねちょっと憶測を
信じますかあの wikipedia を含めあのネットの情報にはあまり流されない
してくださいっていうことで俺の1メディア
始め車道の wikipedia あるんですけどもあのちょこっ恥ずかしくて
ちゃんと見たことないんですよので今回は私弾み雪を自身ではる目社長が肇社長の
wikipedia 見ていこうと思います
自分のことは自分が一番知ってるんであー違ったことが書いてあったらダメなんですよ
なので始めたちょっと wikipedia もう俺じゃない誰でも勝手に帰って
くださったんですありがとうございますなんですけど
をあってないことあるかもしれないそれはしっかり訂正しなきゃいけないと思うんで
早速普及では早速びてぃ
早速にくいで上げていこうと思います
間違ってたら誰か訂正同じですか
では早速行きましょうほらもうはじめ冊うって言ったらすぐ出ていますユーチューバー
はいもうこの一番最初にあるのかもう wikipedia ですねはい行きました
はじめ社長のウィキペディアでございます改めて見ると怖いなちょっと順番に見ていき
ますね端3冊を
1993年平成5年2月
中4日は日本の男性ユーチューバー
う無所属本名は得たはじめ
あってますねうん誰かいターンめっちゃ
なんかすごい強くなってきたらここから先がとうとうら辺の情報はも誰でも知ってると
思うんですよ相性ははじめ
もやし端をなど
2分
[音楽]
たまに呼ばれることはあったような気がします決議型 ab型
俺と顔ですね
若干悪意があるか
うーんなんかちょっと顔が歪んでる感じますけど届かずを書いたりできるんだから自分
で書いといて良いこれログインしなきゃいけないんだ
ちょっと理解度いてください着便な画像にしておいてくださいを人物
きましたね中締め110913/02/1428歳日本
富山県砺波す全部当てます職業ユーチューバー身長185センチアーチャー
oc 俺身長186センチなんですよ美味しいですねちょっと何か修正処理が2
ちゃんねるがはじめ冊を張ってみた超2始めたその畑活動期間が2012年あってます
ねもうすぐ9年なんで山るがコメディー
そうな登録させるがあっていますこれではなく変動する数字だからちょっとわかんない
けどは子はここから何声なんかないで切ってるんだこれはい
生い立ち
19932月10家庭負けた試しにて修正
元気でいてほしいとの思いから始めと付けられた gacchi だ
すごい自信は動画内で中高生のこの生徒会で副会長になるなと
学校でグループ内の馳浩にいるタイプだったと語ってうわーなんかすごいたちと結構
あってる気がします何度やこんな感じで風チーク開始後
2013で大学の
同級生の十月の初め甲板に4組 youtube 動画投稿開始
初めて投稿した動画の再生回数は3回だったんです12回ですごく自分で9回再生し
ましたでその後個人チャンネル開設名前を漢字書ならない海とあってますね
あ
暗い過去も書いてあります江淮皆さんずいぶんでみてくださいねなんか全体的にあっ
てる披露する部分
影響力と困るなマツコさんさんで言ってくださったという話もあっている
田中さんの頃なビジネス記録をとってもあっているすごいなぁ
そうですねうん
そういう月もあっうわぁ凄い凄い畑のことをめっちゃ書いてるぞ
焼酎年バートンを開いて私は誕生日も血液型も全部書いてあるじゃんはもっと焼酎
ネバー
準レギュラーケンスケ島根のねどういうことどういうこと圭佑島根のねって言っ
研究の本命を主はねえなんでこれみんな
の方面を出てる子は5段のせっ身長静岡県で縦目の出身地の静岡で誰かが注釈を入れて
くれてるんだこれまあ
などでコア俺は言ってることのってんだけど本人は外自分で9回再生したから助けずれ
てくれですよやばいは怖い怖い怖いあーなパット3回ちゃうけどじゃない何か僕の今
まで処女とかもちゃんと書いてあって
ちょっと見るの辛いあったです今までも今全てをまとめて載っているのは
wikipedia ですから良いことも取っていれば悪いことを持っているそれが
wikipedia でございますあと1
[音楽]
顔の画像を変えてくれいっ
あっは
[音楽]
blr